since the controversial referendum
earlier this month granted turkeys
leader unprecedented powers Ankara bid
to join the EU has come under fire the
other one sleaze light emits an Invicta
to you to partner shaft matura page 92
[ __ ] 8 in the file system is Nishida
seen daddy album definite Austria had
called just scrapped her his candidacy
altogether others wanted to spend the
talks indefinitely saying the country
may still remain a candidate even if its
current government defies European
values volio record are a colonial-era
pea non Boleyn al Komodo q dair a
LaPorta Alpo below Porco al tempo say so
non pas si amo volt our seed a lot
repartee
Levante - unique a ban on Lady ratio no
pasta a valerie casserole a bass a
delicacy oniy europea
there are millions of people in Turkey
that do share the same European values
millions that do want the EU to remain
the anchor for reforms in their country
and therefore I also don't agree with
those in this farmers world to scrap
turkey for once and for all as a EU
candidate country some fear and abrupt
end to the decade long courtship may
upset the latest deal with Ankara on
refugees an official suspension in any
case would mean an end to the 600
million euros granted every year to
Turkey to part of its pre-accession
package Europe's leaders are likely to
make decisions to stomach
[Music]